is it safe to say you're the World's
foremost UFO expert I I certainly hope
not I I sincerely [__] hope not yeah
so uh you know I think that there's a
lot of people that been working on this
issue for a long time uh probably the
least likely candidate to to be you know
kind of so deep into this I didn't think
I'd ever be professionally studying UFOs
or whatever the hell you say um but you
know right tool for the right job people
say I'm a tool so there you go um now
you like you claim yourself to be a
journalist I do that for self-defense
yes okay yeah did did journalism uh
prede the
UFO yeah the the fascination with this
unknown bizarre phenomenon um no not at
all I was a martial athlete I started
training Jiu-Jitsu when I was a young
kid boxing wrestling all that stuff and
I thought that's all I'd ever do for my
whole life you know and then you get
injured really bad at some point and you
can't do the same stuff so transition
from that to to Fine Art which was again
total impostor syndrome I can't draw a
stick figure but that started for me I
kind of got into that but the whole time
along I was interested in UFOs like the
nuts and bolts the hardcore physical
craft the idea and then the journalism
thing was I just pastored this guy
[__] over and over his name is George
[__] NP he's a he's an
investigative reporter out of Las Vegas
Nevada and I figured he if anybody knew
what the [__] was up what was true what
was not true good starting point so he
goes to me for like two years then
finally I got through to him and you
know he kind of mentored me now for over
a decade so that the title of journalist
was bestowed upon me by the public so
I'll accept it because it provides me uh
additional coverage in a way I am
reporting the news I am breaking news
but I never thought of myself like that
never never studied journalism but I
learned from the best so that's kind of
and in between that I made movies about
UFOs you know was also unexpected like
the Bob Lazar movie right right and so
that kind of thrust me into a position
where people were confiding in me things
that they hadn't told their families
hadn't told their children haden't
whispered to their dogs you know I me
it's like right it's so kind of
accidental uh journalist but the first
movies that you made made it on Netflix
yeah the [__] insane right I mean you
have three movies on Netflix right so
two on Netflix one on Hulu and now
they're kind of everywhere because I
took them off the platform so look
here's the deal man I figured that I
would just try and so I just made a
movie and to my utter astonishment it
got picked up on Netflix and went wild
and that was before the Lazar film it's
called patient 17 yeah so I figured well
if is that
easy keep it up I think I got real lucky
and hopefully I made good films yeah how
long did that take you to make the first
movie you know it's funny man um when
you say you make a movie like a
documentary a lot of people got a plan
so they're like oh I start now I get
funding I do n no dude I had a camera
that I got for my wedding and I started
pointing it at people and realized they
would spill the [__] beans and so it
was at that moment I said well I should
learn to edit so I started putting it
all together and if you add up all the
time of the the first shot and all that
stuff I mean it takes years for me I'm
probably not the best there's probably
people that are way more efficient than
me but um I would say like the Lazar
film The the third film I did I mean
that took maybe 9 years from inception
cuz I didn't know if he would do the
film with me yeah so man I don't know
I'm doing it all the wrong ways but it's
they're coming out these are you know
movies about this topic yeah do you like
shopping on Amazon I do and good news is
sto's butt wipes for your butthole are
available on
Amazon and if you want a real bundle of
a deal you can get sto's hot sauce for
your butthole plus sto's butthole
destroyer and sto's butt wipes for your
butthole it's the butthole bundle
available on Amazon right
now yeah dude